نذهب الى اسطنبول الان ومعنا من هناك
صحفيه طه عوده اوغلو اهلا بك استاذ طه
معنا في صباح العربيه يسعد صباحك صف طه
اليوم انتم تعيشون في تركيا نريد ان نعرف
ما هو وضع تركيا عندما يتعلق بالزلازل
فيما يتعلق بالسوابق التاريخيه للزلازل
هناك
صباح الخير يا استاذه نادين لكم وللساده
المشاهدين يعني دون شك يعني تركيا تعيش
منذ سنوات طويله او تتعايش مع الزلازل
ذكرتي قبل قليل ان هناك عدد كبير من
الزلازل تعرضت لها تركيا وكان اعتقد
اكبرها هو في منطقه ارزنجان في عام 1939
نعم في السابع عشر من اغسطس 99 كان زلزال
مدمرا للغايه وحتى ان هناك بعض المناطق هي
منطقه تسمى غولجو كونا هي خرجت من الخارطه
هي دخلت في البحر في تلك الفتره وهناك
الاف يعني الحديث عن 17,000 ولكن
المعلومات كانت تتحدث عن 40 او 60 الف
والان الزلزال الذي حدث
بالامس هو عدا الذكريات الاليمه وخاصه
طيله السنوات الماضيه هناك نعم
تعيشها تركيا وخاصه فيما يتعلق بالزلازل
ان كانت في المدن الكبرى وعدد كبير من
المدن الاخرى يعني استاذ طه اخر زلزال
مدمر ضرب تركيا يمكن القول حصل قبل 25
عاما طوال ال 25 عاما ماذا فعلت تركيا
مثلا من اجراءات معينه وخصوصا وانها منطقه
نشطه للزلازل هل تم تطوير بنيه تحتيه
البنايات اصبحت مهيئه مؤهله نوعا ما ام
ماذا
صحيح نعم اعتقد يعني هو بعد زلزال تسعه
وتسعين كانت هناك الانظار متوجهه الى
البنيه التحتيه في تركيا ولكن كانت كل
الخبراء يركزون ويؤكدون دائما بان مدينه
اسطنبول هي مقبله على زلزال مدمر لذا
لاحظنا ان خلال السنوات الماضيه حتى
تتابعين هنا في وسائل الاعلام التركيه
الخبراء يتحدثون بان اسطنبول بعد شهر او
شهرين او سنه او سنتين ولكن لم يكن
التركيز في بعض المناطق التي حصلت بالامس
يعني اشرت لك الحادث او الزلزال الذي وقع
بالامس في كهرمان مراج في منطقه جازا
انتيب هي مناطق نائيه والبنيه تحتيه ضعيفه
للغايه خاصه ان هذه المناطق هي بعيده
والقرب من الحدود السوريه التركيز بشكل
كبير كان في مدينه اسطنبول يعني نتحدث
مدينه اسطنبول تقريبا 24 عام على مرور
زلزال ازمير او ازميد الى حتى هذه اللحظه
هناك معلومات تتحدث عن ان 128 الف منزل
معرض
للزنزال اذا حصل هنا لا سمح الله في مدينه
اسطنبوسه فيكون هنا مدمر للغايه نعم
الحكومه التركيه قامت خلال الفتره الاخيره
الماضيه لكن هناك بعض الظروف السياسيه بعد
الظروف الاقتصاديه كان لها تاثير لذا ان
التصور اعتقد هذا
الحادث او هذا الزلزال الكبير الذي وقع
بالامس هو يعني حقيقه يعني اختبار كبير
للحكومه التركيه وحتى لكافه يعني هنا
المسؤولين داخل تركيا حسب سؤالك ماذا فعلت
طيله السنوات الماضيه طيب استاذ طه لا
ادري ان كنت موجود في تركيا ومقيم هناك في
عام 1999 يعني هذا الزلزال ما قبل الاخير
المدمر كيف يعود المواطنون الاتراك
ويستفيق ويستيقظوا من هول الفاجعه وهول
الصدمه متى تعود بعدها الحياه الى طبيعتها
نعم يعني انا في السابع عشر من اغسطس يعني
عشت وهنا في مدينه اسطنبول
كانت حقيقه فاجعه تقريبا في تلك الفتره 45
ثانيه مده الزلزال يعني لاحظنا ان هناك
الحياه عاده يمكن تقريبا بعد اسبوع وحاله
من الخوف
والهلع تحدث عن مدينه اسطنبول في تلك
الفتره هي تعرضت الى هناك دمار كامل في
منطقه تسمى هي في القسم الاوروبي في
اسطنبول ولكن الكارثه الكبرى كانت هي
بالقرب من اسطنبول بعد على بعد ساعات اقصد
مدينه منطقه اسميت وحتى وهي منطقه بحريه
كاجتك قبل قليل هي يعني اختفت عن الخارطه
وايضا هناك بعدها بشهرين تقريبا في 99 في
نوفمبر هناك كان زلزال اخر زلزال يسمى
روسيا وكان هو اخر هو الاخر بزلزال مدمرا
للغايه
[موسيقى]